hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
the role of interferon gamma release
assay testing in the era of covid19
i am cj valdez of elaborate and i will
be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by deosorin
to learn more visit them at diasoren.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting
any questions you might have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain
those credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits window
i'd now like to introduce and welcome
our speaker dr
wendy fenassi the chief and occupational
health at va
paul palo alto health care system
and associate clinical professor at the
population
health and epidemiology at stanford
university
dr thanasi welcome you may now begin
your presentation
well a good day everybody my name is
wendy tanasi as you heard dr tanasi and
i'm just
honored to be speaking today
about tuberculosis and the role of
interferon gamma assays
and testing in tv and in this era of
covet 19. you know it's just
been quite quite a ride this last year
or two
it is the second world tv day
and the end of the first full year since
we encountered covet 19
together and i know all of you all of us
worked absolutely feverishly to manage
this pandemic
and its consequences and what we're
going to talk about today
is um what has the kopit 19
pandemic what effect has it had on
tuberculosis and on management out there
in the world so we put together a couple
of key learning objectives
i um hope you enjoy our little run
through tb in the world i guess it's not
really enjoyable since
the reason we have world tb day is that
it's such a crisis in the world
but what we're hoping to do is work
together toward elimination so let's
look at some key learning objectives
we will review the impact of covid19
pandemic on the
incidence of tuberculosis in the world
we'll review some recent
u.s public health data on tuberculosis
and latent tb infection
ltbi including some testing and
diagnostic methods and the role of
igras which are the blood tests and
latent tb treatment in these challenging
times
looks like there's a repeat there that's
just maybe to emphasize the point
so again i would like to just give you a
little personal background about why
this matters to me
this uh interest in tuberculosis and
diagnostics happened when i
took a sabbatical from training at yale
and worked for three months in the
southern cape i was assigned a project
called predictors of mortality
in the brooklyn chest hospital in the
western cape there were only two to
three hundred beds available for a
population of 10 million
to treat for tuberculosis and so they
were very coveted beds and what they
found was there was still a population
who admitted there who died
and they asked me to figure out if i
could if i could help
work on predicting who was going to die
anyway
so that those were not people who were
admitted to the hospital and instead
other people who were more likely to
survive the treatment would be
admitted it's a terrible place to be in
it's not something that we face in the
united states that kind of limited
resource and i was very uncomfortable
with it
but what we learned in the end was not
what i expected and if we were live i
would ask you what you thought the
predictors of mortality were usually i
hear it's older age or malnutrition
in fact the people who died in the
brooklyn trust hospital
despite being treated before drug
therapy for tuberculosis
were people who were misdiagnosed as
having tuberculosis
that is they actually had lymphoma or
they actually had meningococcemia or
another disease that they died of
because they were misdiagnosed as having
tuberculosis
and that was a huge lipo
event for me and i really learned that
if we get the diagnosis
correct we can do anything and if we get
the diagnosis long
we can cause a great deal of harm and
even death and actually down there is a
paper we put in the south african
medical journal
so diagnostics became a real passion of
mine and tuberculosis
uh is of course what followed now world
tv day is a tragic day it's
actually march 24th i'm waiting for the
time that it is
you know no longer necessary
in 1882 when dr koch announced his
discovery of mycobacterium tuberculosis
and
it's kind of fun if you get to see any
pictures he brings down a microscope and
very grandiose form in front of a big
audience of
medical students and have them look
under the microscope of the stained
microbacterium
and it's pretty exciting because i
hadn't seen it before
but where we are today with tuberculosis
is the understanding that it actually
causes more death than any infectious
disease in the world
and a quarter of the world's population
is infected with the tuberculosis
mycobacterium
interestingly tb is actually curable and
it's preventable
about 85 of active tb cases can be
successfully treated with a
six-month drug regimen and the
additional benefit of treating people is
that that curtails the onward
transmission of infection to other
people
but to get people especially in the
lesser developed countries to
take a multi-drug regimen every day for
six months requires an incredible
um it's a great word an incredible
commitment of time and resources and
mostly those
are low paid and low educated community
health workers but with their adherence
there is great success so that in the
20 years steve and has averted about 63
million
deaths worldwide so what's happening
with kovid in the world
well the prediction for the world health
welfare health organization
and they expected about one and a half
million deaths and with
t with covid and tv tb together they're
predicting another half a million deaths
per year
um due to multiple causes primarily a
decrease in tb
case detection so the new york times
carried an interesting article in august
of 2020 when everybody's
you know obviously we've all been very
embroiled in
covid they said look what is happening
to tuberculosis
poverty worldwide is increasing
malnutrition
is therefore going to increase and the
availability of pb testing is down
worldwide because everybody
is being converted to covid testing
clinics so
circovid testing
tb surveillance programs they were
repurposed
um to be testing for covid in
india the diagnoses were down by 75
india probably
uh that had really short-term
implications obviously but
really long-term implications if tb has
just been allowed
to continue to move forward with active
cases and transmission
we are going to expect a spike in tb
cases worldwide
meanwhile as you know with everything
closing treatment supply stain
disruptions occurred
and we learned of course that there's
co-infection not just with hiv and tb
but now of course hiv and tb and covid
and they
look alike right both pulmonary
infections both with cough both with
fever
um part of why the diagnosis of
tuberculosis went so far down is
everything was called
covid okay just a little side light here
that i think is kind of fun and
interesting there was a lot of talk
early on in covet 19 about whether bcg
vaccination might impart some protection
against the sars kovi coronavirus
covid19 of many names um
so the bcg vaccine as you might know has
been around about 130 years
and it is the only vaccine we have in
the world against tuberculosis it's
it's relatively effective it certainly
saves a lot of lives and there are many
variations of it across the world
so it's interesting that coveted 19 has
killed fewer people in these severely
impoverished and less developed
countries than we expect
and i don't think it's a matter of lack
of adequate diagnostics because
the overall mortality rates in those
countries are not significantly higher
not where we would really expect them if
they were being
influenced by covenant 19 as we predict
so
one really does wonder if there's some
efficacy to the bcg vaccine so the world
health organization addressed this early
in the pandemic in april of 2020 and
they said no no no
there's no evidence that the bcg
protects
against infection and then they said
that they're following it with some
clinical trials well
these are not their clinical trials but
two papers that came out
about six months later in like august
and september
of last year did point to the
possibility that bcg is inferring some
protection
and we have seen other papers earlier
that it does protect against
um it seems to against rsv and some
other childhood
uh viruses so i just think that's a
little
fun side light um and it leaves a lot of
room
for more study and maybe for a little
bit of good news
in the darkness that was last year
so going back to now moving from the
world and the influence of covet 19 and
tuberculosis in the world to the united
states and some of our public health
issues
you probably are all working in the
field of tuberculosis and like me were
completely pulled out of what you did
before
and moved 100 to covet 19 response and
this was a little study done by the
national tv controllers
that showed that over 90 percent of tb
programs had actually deployed personnel
from the united states to the code19
response
and um you know over 60 percent of them
had experienced a high
uh nearly high impact on staffing and
then what we see from that is that
diagnosis of tuberculosis in the united
states were way down
since kovid's starting and that doesn't
mean that tuberculosis cases are down
it's just that the diagnosis was down
and we saw this happen before and i
would ask you again if we were live like
what
caused the increase in tuberculosis
cases that the united states witnessed
in the late 80s and early 90s and i
don't know what your answer would be
so i just have to tell you that the
answer was hiv
and so we had a public health crisis
in the united states where a lot of
resources again were diverted
to uh this new virus and the spreading
infection that we didn't understand and
tv diagnosis
went down at the time and right
afterwards
a lot um sorry active tuberculosis cases
went way off especially in the area i
live in san francisco
where um we saw quite an
increase and so i feel like tuberculosis
and covid19
are following that same pattern and we
should all be aware
in our practice that we're headed
probably toward an uptick in
tuberculosis well
that's not really the worst thing
because if you look at the entire world
and the incidence of tuberculosis
in the world this is a graphic i made
years ago and i must say modestly it's
one of my favorites
but it shows the incidence of
tuberculosis per 100 000 population in
different countries
and on the x-axis across the bottom is
the list of countries and on the
vertical axis it's the incidence
and in between each of those lines that
you see are
other countries so in between there's
cambodians
and zambia and a bunch of other
countries and then you look at the
incidence decrease as you fall off to
the right
and farthest down on the right
you can see at the essentially zero line
is the united states
we keep company in our tuberculosis
incidents in the united states
with countries like monaco iceland
sweden the british virgin islands
like seriously in the united states we
have so
little tuberculosis that our tb rates
match those of other countries and
that's because our public health has
been extraordinary and fantastic and
we're going to go on to that
um and let me just say that that
means that the united states it's not
that we don't have tb
we have and i'll and i'll get to that
but what we carry in terms of the global
burden of tuberculosis is less than
0.00005
of the global tuberculosis burden is in
the united states
and so we remember that as we go on and
talk about specifying testing for
certain groups
and not just willy-nilly running out and
testing
all 20 million healthcare workers every
year anymore
so let's think about how do we target
our testing so that we know
who we can who can most benefit
so where is tuberculosis in the united
states well over half of the cases are
only in four
states california texas new york and
florida interesting some of the cases
that tb
are the highest in the same places
aren't they i mean i'm sorry of covin
19.
it's kind of interesting well in the
case of tuberculosis if you look at the
graphic on the right
it's actually also in uh the
population primarily it was not born in
the united states
so 71 of all tb in the united states is
people who are born outside of this
country
and 88 of those countries i'm sorry 88
of the cases are in racial or ethnic
minorities now we don't need
any more trouble for our um
lesser represented groups in the united
states but what we do need is help
and so in recognizing that it's racial
and ethnic minorities not born in the
united states and in those
four states in the united states where
tuberculosis
lives right now allows us to target our
testing to the populations who will most
benefit
so where is latent tuberculosis so
latent tv will live inside people for 20
years before it will reactivate
and that's why people who are born in
other countries will have tuberculosis
for
20 30 40 years they might become immune
compromised later and then their latent
tuberculosis wakes up and becomes
active well late in tb in the united
states is a wonderful study and there
there are cited at the bottom of my
slides
that show that 14 million cases of
latent tb are estimated to be in the
united states that's a pretty big number
and what i love about this study is that
was done by one of the interferon gamma
release
assays so usually the testing is done at
nhanes which is an old
tst or skin test study which really
overestimated
the amount of latent tuberculosis in the
united states right because the
the skin test cross-reacts with the bcg
vaccine
and it cross-reacts with non-tuberculous
mycobacterium
but when you use an interferon gamma
release assay there's none of that cross
reaction and you really
are detecting at that point latent
tuberculosis
so 14.1 million cases of
tuberculosis in 2012 different estimate
which was 8.9 million but this was
all estimates assumptions and
calculations it has a wider confidence
interval
from 6 to 15 so that i don't really
rely on that number very much but i
wanted you to see it that's in 2015.
and then what does it cost in the united
states right now it's costing just for
those
9 000 active tb cases a year over 172
million dollars and that is just for
treatment that doesn't even include
exposure investigations which are
enormous
so the united nations the world health
organization that
you see had a goal to eradicate
tuberculosis by 2030 well
that is coming up really soon and with
the coven 19 pandemic we're certainly
going to miss that target
but why don't we eradicate tuberculosis
in the u.s can we do it
i think we can and how do we do it well
we have to use
testing and we have to use targeted
testing of the right people and we have
to use the right test
that means not the skin test anymore and
identify as i mentioned in my south
africa experience identify those who
will benefit from treatment
that requires getting the right
diagnosis well
you might say well why is she showing a
gross slide of guinea worm
well this is why because the final 10
in the goal of elimination is harder
than the first 90 and for those of you
who are in
um finance you know that like if you
want to raise money
you know you can get 90 of the money
pretty quick but if you try to get that
last 10
it can often be um really really
difficult
so that's the same with elimination and
there's a slide on the right of guinea
worm eradication
which shows that 15 years earlier
between 1990
and 2005 we were worldwide
able to decrease cases of guinea worm
from 900 thousand to
ten thousand so by almost you know by
eight hundred and eighty thousand
we decreased the cases of guinea worm in
that 15 years and then in the following
15 years from 2005
to 2020 the last 10
000 cases are get are hard to wipe out
we're down to like 27
so that's what it was in 2020 but you
know you can do 900 000
in the first 15 years but you can can't
finish off that last 10 000 in the next
15 years i think is really fascinating
and guinea worm is yucky
and that was a community health worker
effort as well and a public health
effort
um so that actually going back even
further into 1986 there were
and there were an estimated 3.6 million
cases
but we're almost eliminating that from
the world
second um to polio it's one of the
greatest
public health campaigns there is so
didn't mean to digress back from the
united states but to
draw the parallel that we are down below
10
now in the united states and how are we
going to wipe it out well this final 10
of tuberculosis in the u.s these cases
come from transmission
these come from transmission so
controlling recent transmission is a
vital component of our tb elimination
strategy
so 80 of all of the active tb cases are
reactivation of latent db
in the populations that i've already
mentioned right those who are foreign
born and certain racial and ethnic
minorities
and then when they reactivate there's a
spread to an average of nine
other people from active tuberculosis
from latent to active
so i'm sorry that's not accurate so
there is a spread for each active case
to nine
other people those nine other people
will have latent tuberculosis and some
of them will reactivate in the first two
years
so every time you treat one person with
active tb effectively before they have
transmitted to
nine other people we are working toward
that elimination goal really quickly
so latent tb treatment after we've made
the diagnosis is absolutely crucial it
prevents reactivation which then also
prevents
transmission and we have to break this
cycle
okay how are we going to do that well
there's only two diagnostic tests
available
in the united states outside of the skin
test which i don't even really want to
address because that's also been around
about 130 years and has outlived its
lifetime
it has a few select roles but not so
many so what are the interferon gamma
release assets there's two
available in the united states one is by
the oxford company it's called the tbt
spot you probably know about it it's a
whole blood assay
it's a single or sometimes people will
draw two green top tubes of whole blood
drop it i call it a um it's a test it's
a
it's a tv test in a box so you just
draw the whole blood and then the
laboratory drops it into their
pre-filled fedex boxes and sends it off
to their laboratory which is in memphis
tennessee
and that was moved from boston because
they had so many weather delays now
having your main laboratory in memphis
tennessee is okay but there was
obviously a lot of disruption this year
when the plane
stopped flying because of soviet
nineteen so you have to realize if you
choose to do this cycle separation assay
which is pretty complicated
as your main test then you will
be beholden to the air carriers
the other main interference gamma
release assay in the united states is
the quantifier on gold in
tube plot which is a terrible name but
i'm not paid by either of these
companies
so i can say that um so the quantiferon
plus as we shorten it is a four
tube assay or a single grain top which
you can see in the picture on the right
so you can draw into a single green top
and then in the laboratory it needs to
be aliquoted into these four tubes
it's an elisa which is an enzyme-linked
immunoassay it's run on a lot of common
machines and it's run on platforms
in many laboratories across the united
states whereas the t
spot is run in like 55 different labs or
so last i checked
but really those are minor and
specialized
compared to um like in university
academic hospitals compared to the main
laboratory in memphis the
eliza poniferon is run almost everywhere
including most public health departments
i think their costs are relatively
similar
the the cbt spot might cost a little bit
more it depends on the contracts that
are negotiated
so that i agree test let's talk about
that what is the interferon gamma
release
assay look like so when i came to the
palo alto va
we were like everybody else in like 2009
doing just the skin test and we had
about a 30
positive rate on the skin test in our
workforce now our workforce has a lot of
people in our local area come from the
philippines from mexico from vietnam
and that was the majority of those skin
tests that were positive we switched
them
all over we switched them all
over to using the interferon gamma
release assay we tested all those
positives and all those negatives
and what we found was we were able to
drop our positivity rate
to almost eight percent from 30 percent
and then in retesting those eight
percent who were positive we dropped it
down to 3.5
and i can do a whole other talk on
reversions
and and igras and none of you want to
hear that at this point
but what i do want to say is like
everything in that pie chart those are
all
people and when you're able to tell
26 of the
of your population or almost 95
of the people who thought that they were
positive that they're
actually not you get tears because
they're scared of having tuberculosis
they don't want to have it they don't
want to infect their families they don't
want to reactivate and get sick
themselves
so switching from the skin test to the
interferon gamma release assays
is an amazing amazing accomplishment for
the
world of tuberculosis diagnostics and
it's why i've committed much of my
career
to learning the nuances of the
diagnostics and you can ask questions
afterwards about those if you would like
to
but suffice it to say that in 2017 the
american thoracic society the infectious
disease society of america
and the centers for disease control all
got together
and agreed in this paper that
agrees are recommended for diagnose
diagnosis of tuberculosis
over the skin test in nearly every
single
not that they're equal but they're
recommended over the tst
and remember going back to south africa
if we get the diagnosis
right we do no harm and we do do good
but let's look at what happened with
this new quantifier on plus and i'm
picking on that one because it's much
more commonly used
than the the t-spot so what happens is
out here in the blue circle are all the
people
working in the phlebotomy centers and
they're
you know drawing blood and all these
different centers and there's the poor
person working
in the laboratory and they're receiving
the tubes from all those people
out in the field and so initially those
people in the field let's say like each
of them draws
three green tops three individual
quantifier on that day
and they send them in to the little
poor overworked person in the laboratory
all of a sudden that person in the
laboratory is trying to handle
this many tubes literally i like cut and
paste them on there
so this person in the laboratory is
handling like
hundreds of tubes alone and they're
alloquatting them and they're shaking
them
and they're incubating them and they're
labeling them and they're trying to run
this assay either manually or
on eliza machines obviously we have
gotten to a point where we need
automation so that we can have
consistency in our results and accuracy
in our diagnosis and there's
lots of papers out that show the
accuracy and some of the foibles
of um particularly the quantiferon plots
like i said because it's used more often
but what there is also been with the
revolution in diagnostics is a
revolution in
automation and an efficiency which we
need
so again with that one test
there were a couple of partnerships made
between their
company which is kyogen and other
companies and the one that went through
the fda in 2019
is a partnership with a laboratory
company called diasoren
where they have an automated testing
platform called like liaison and the
liaison xl
it's a chemiluminescent assay and their
machine just like all the machines
previously will run
multiple tests and what will happen is
post incubation
they can automate all the testing
everything's labeled the caps come off
everything's aliquoted
and they'll run this menu of other tests
as well
there were some other partnerships as
well between that company
kaiogen there was one between tcan which
is their fluent machine
and hamilton robotics and their micro
lab machine now
they sign non-exclusive agreements with
kaiogen
and i'm just showing you this because
the future of this test is definitely
this kind of automation
and i think it's really cool i believe
the only fda approved platform is this
diaphorin
liaison liaison xl so
i just have a little video here because
this is so
super cool of one of the companies
i just think this is amazing look at
that they'll even shake the tubes for
you so that's what they call their
rotisserie
and the little the pipettes on the right
um on other machines will actually
unscrew the tops of the tubes and
aliquot
and then spin and then shake and it's
really quite amazing
and all of these innovations are leading
us toward better care
i meant to push next i'm sorry i pushed
the wrong button okay so
um what on this slide you see the
evolution like we've seen the evolution
of diagnostics we see the evolution of
these automated platforms and i'm just
showing you i don't know how many of you
are laboratorians
or how close you work with your lab but
i used to go into the lab all the time
i lobbied for these two machines that
have the red arrows the d
at first we had a ds2 and then we had a
dsx
and um they worked for us
but the ds2 only took two plates
of 96 wells or 26 tests per
hour and a half run and so we only ran
like
two you know sort of like 26 to 48
people a day on that which was not
adequate and then we got a dsx and i
must say honestly it never worked for us
for more than two plates anyway so that
wasn't really an improvement
my laboratory has not been able to move
to these other ones
that you see on this slide but as i
mentioned they exist
and some of the major laboratories do
have them and the accuracy
of those tests and the importance of
getting the diagnostic capability is
really crucial
so if you have any pull in your
laboratory you might lobby for some of
these automated machines
last thing i want to bring up in the
last two slides is the treatment arm so
once you've made
the once you've picked your population
um and
and run the appropriate test and now
you've got a diagnosis of latent
tuberculosis what do you do well this
is the greatest thing since sliced bread
if you live in my world this
is 3 hp treatment it came out
in like 20 i don't remember
2009 maybe 2011 that it was approved as
a directly observed therapy it is now
a self-administered therapy sat which
means
this is three months of once a week
for 12 weeks i'm going to say that again
you can treat latent tuberculosis
with one day a week of antibiotics for
12 weeks
that means 12 days of antibiotics is now
the treatment the first line treatment
for latent tuberculosis
not 270 days like when you used to do
six to nine months of inh
this is um inh plus rifapentine
it is um pretty big doses some people
get nausea and some people get allergic
reactions to the rifapentine but in
pretty minor amounts there's no
laboratory testing that's done along the
way
if you have a reliable population of
people like your healthcare workers
please please please please please treat
them for latent tuberculosis and i
should have put a slide in here
of the mmwr from 2019 that came out that
says we are moving from just doing the
testing to making sure we always do the
treatment for latent tb along with the
testing
and that's because that is how we
eliminate tb
that's how we eliminate it we're down to
like
under 10 percent if we can get people on
board to stop just
testing people and saying hey you have
latent tb you know high fives do a
questionnaire and
onto hey i've got this great thing i've
got 12
days of antibiotics that we can use to
treat you
we will eliminate tb in the united
states so moving on to the second to
last slide there are actually
three short course regimens that are the
first
line treatment and this is a joe article
that i actually was first
author on it's the companion document to
the mmwr
and so this nice little paste out chart
there you can hang over your desk
there's three hp treatment there's four
months of
once a day rifampin treatment
and then there's a combination of
inhibit pentene that you can array
sampling that you can do for three
months and then there's the old school
of
six months or nine months of inh on that
chart
again all of the short course regimens
are um
are preferred over the long course
okay and so then in summary we're almost
done
the covet 19 global pandemic is poised
to cause millions of additional deaths
from tuberculosis in the next few years
and that's due to decreased diagnosis
treatment supply shortages
decreased access to treatment and
increased poverty
the most crucial step you can all take
is getting the correct diagnosis
and that means taking advantage of these
uh improvements these
new and improved tests we have the
quantiferon plus there's a
magnetic tvt spot bead test that's being
tested in europe
now there's these nucleic acid
amplification tests like the gene
expert that are used internationally
there are partnerships between
laboratory companies
and the makers of these wonderful
interferon gamma
release assays there are acquisitions
labquest
actually bought the tbt spot uh
facility in memphis and so that's a new
partnership that's going to improve
reliability these are coming fast and
furious
there's improved processes and
automation that increase the consistency
of results as i mentioned
but we have to use these tests correctly
we have to use them on a correct option
and that is what impacts the reliability
if we keep testing 20 million
negative health care workers we're going
to get false positives if we
test the right people like you think
about that clinic i mentioned
in um in south africa if we
target the right people we get the right
diagnosis and the right treatment but
without vaccine
it's only through this method of
accurate diagnosis
and fulfillment of treatments that will
allow us to eliminate tuberculosis
in the united states i really believe we
can do it
uh so oh yeah that one said all of you
all of us have the power and we now have
the tools to be part of eliminating
tuberculosis in the u.s i want to thank
you
very very much for your time and your
attention i hope i didn't run overtime
we're hoping to have some time now for
questions
and um i will be glad to hear what you
have to say and what your thoughts are
about this brave new world
um uh power be with you
to take care of that other respiratory
illness
that affects so many people in the world
and and thank you thank you happy world
tb day
and thank you dr athanasi for that
informative presentation
we will now start that live q a portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look dr tanasi we have
quite a few
questions already coming in looks like
we have some
already readied our first question is
is there an interaction between
igras and covid vaccine
so that's a terrific question and even i
got a call this warning
from somebody in texas about this
because it's a real problem so let me
tell you what's going on
the problem is that the centers for
disease control and prevention
has been putting out recommendations
fast and furious through covet
that are often based on
you know look they're they're great
people they're my friends they're doing
their best
but they're often based on old data and
information and they're just doing their
best to give advice that advice is often
very conservative
so there is not an interaction that is
shown between
igris and the coveted vaccine again
there is no interaction shown or known
there is no data published on that
there are no studies that show that that
has happened and i'm speaking almost
daily with people at the cdc about that
so the recommendation came out that one
should not get a tb test within a couple
weeks of getting a coveted vaccine based
on some 1970s studies of live vaccines
and interaction with the skin test so
if you get a lot of vaccine and you're
very reactogenic maybe the wheel of the
skin test
is a little bit larger well the covich
vaccines are not live vaccines
and the test that most people are doing
is not the skin tests
so the recommendation to weight between
the covid vaccine and the igra
is very conservative outdated
and not based on any direct science i'm
not saying you should go against what
the cdc says
um but if you're going to base it on
medical probability you you can go ahead
and give
and take them together safely until we
see some data that there's any sort of
interaction
so thank you for that question thank you
so much
now is the dsorin liaison system
an alisa platform
is it an elisa platform yeah the
enzyme-linked immunoassay it sure is
um the the
the liaison system is a is an integrated
test
um that's been worked out between the
two of them that's between the company
and
the the laboratory company and the
diagnostic company so the eliza
enzyme-linked immunoassay is an old uh
test been you know it's a diagnostic
technique that's been around for many
years
where you can coat a plate um and then
layer on top of it different antigens
and different reagents and substances
and then get a reading for a reaction
that occurs in that well
so the nice thing about it being an
elisa platform is that eliza platforms
commonly used so measles mumps rubella
varicella
vitamin d esr many of the common tests
run in laboratories are also elisa
platform tests and that means that this
liaison
xl machine will also those tests
depending on the software that's loaded
from your company
um so the the giant-ness of the machine
um that i've seen is not isolated to
using it just for tuberculosis but can
be used for all the other things
that your laboratory is using doing on
the eliza platform
thank you so much dr thank you when we
have some great questions coming in i
want to thank our audience
keep on asking these wonderful questions
our next question
is igra more valuable than
tst whatever is the level of anomicity
and ethnicity yeah that's a great
question so the person's asking
you know is igram more valuable in tst
no matter where so
i have different answers to that we did
a very elaborate cost analysis that we
totally should have published and just
didn't get down to that final few
little percentage financially
the value of the agra versus the cost of
the tst
um if you're doing a low risk population
you are in a financially better place
sometimes doing the tst
but that's kind of a complicated
question i apologize
um financially there's a
dr sanasi it looks like we lost your
um sound the more
there oh i'm sorry
it looks like we lost just
okay so i don't have a perfect answer
for that i think the
um the end ethnicity always affects the
uh outcome of the test and so the higher
the pretest probability of a disease
the more accurate the test becomes and
that would be true for the skin test as
well
but the igra does not interact
with the bcg vaccine so the problem with
the skin test is when your pre-test
probability is that it's going to be
positive and that's why you're doing the
skin test
because somebody has come in from like
the philippines where it's the ninth
highest
rate of tb in the world or they've come
in from mexico or another highly endemic
country
so you're doing a tb test you want the
result to be accurate and with the tst
there's so much cross-reaction with the
bcp
vaccine and with the um like
non-mycobacterium
tuberc non-mycobacterium bacterium
that you will end up with too many false
positives so
i don't have the really good settings
where the tst
is um better used than the igra i think
in almost all settings the igra
its accuracy outperforms the tst i think
really you're looking at operational
needs
so if you're someplace where you don't
have easy access to a laboratory where
you don't have
the equipment or the machinery needed
then skin test is perfectly accurate um
or adequate and so i'm sorry for that
ramble that's what happens when you get
live
questions okay sorry please succeed
this is this is great and i want to
thank again our audience for these great
questions coming in
dr athanasi how important is it to
report out the numeric
value along with the qualitative results
positive negative indeterminate when
reporting
results for qfg
yeah i love that question how important
it is is it to report out the results so
what happens with the quantifier on test
as you all probably know is you might
get
one qualitative answer positive or
negative from a laboratory
but let's go through this real quickly
because it's a terrific question and
vitally important
the quantifier on test i showed you it
has the four tubes it has a nil tube
which is a negative control
the value in that tube should be
essentially zero it has a
mitogen tube which is i sort of call it
like a garbage can it's a
tube that's coated with
phytohemaglutinin from from kidney bean
slurry
which is highly highly reactive so when
somebody's whole blood goes into it and
comes
into contact with the edges of the tube
where this pha
exists there's a huge release of
interferon gamma
and that positive control tells you that
the person's immune system is working
well
and if you think about tuberculosis as
an active disease
it's predominantly in people who are
immune compromised
so it was crucial to the companies to
know
that you weren't getting a false
negative
so that by having a positive control
that says
yes they have a working immune system it
then allows the next two tubes in the
case of the quantifier on
the tb antigen one tube and the tb
anagen 2 tube to be reliable results
so when you get the results from the
laboratory i
really want to see this i want to see
that the nil background is low i want to
see that the mitogen is high
and then the tb antigen one and two so
what happens is the whole blood comes in
and it also reacts in these separate
tubes against the walls of the tube that
are coated with
very specific tb antigens the same ones
that are used in the tbt spot the eset 6
and cfp10
so when the whole blood comes into
contact with those
antigens if the body has seen it before
it will release all sorts of interferon
gamma
if a body's never seen it before it
remains neutral and nothing really
happens
now the cutoff point of zero points
greater than 0.35 international units
per milliliter was set by the fda
in order to give a 99.9
i believe it could be 99.5
um
to the test so just because somebody
tests quote-unquote positive and their
tb antigen
value is 0.37 or 0.40 or 0.42
or 0.70 does not mean they have
tuberculosis
it's just another number on the scale it
means that they're
only 99.3 percent likely to be negative
or 98.8 likely to be negative
so thank you for the question you really
definitely want to look at those values
if you get a positive result
a qualitative result that's a positive
on anybody who you don't believe had
tuberculosis your pre-test probability
was low
you definitely want to assess that
result quantitatively
and redraw the test and that is within
2019
cdc mmwr says redraw
all of the unexpected positives in fact
even potentially all of your positives
um i wanted to add something to that um
and i lost that train of thought but
it's a it's a terrific
question so think about retesting
definitely know the quantitative values
oh i was going to
tell you that in 2010 the cdc
came out with guidance that directs all
laboratories to report those
quantitative values
so you can refer back to the cdc on
tuberculosis in 2010
on their document on tuberculosis and
igras if you need support for the
laboratory to
report out those specific values so i
try to be faster on those
thank you so much now what is the role
of the nat testing
so the nucleic acid amplification
testing is completely
fantastic the load company near me
cepheid in sunnyvale runs has the test
the gene
expert e-x-p-e-r-t it's a different test
so that test is um
a sputum test that's used to diagnose
active tuberculosis and its
real benefit is telling you resistance
patterns
so when so there's a couple of benefits
to it so if you're in
particularly well so anyone who you see
who has active tv
you definitely want to get a gene expert
and look at the resistance to inh or
vampin or the other members of the of
the race
initial treatment platform the other
great role for using the nucleic acid
amplification is to release people from
isolation in your hospital quicker than
three days
so instead of putting waiting that three
days for the three sequential
morning sputums to be done and then
smeared in the laboratory you could
actually run a gene expert
quickly using the nucleic acid
amplification technique
and released that person from isolation
which has been shown to save a lot of
money
and of course saves a lot of fear and
time and ppe use
so those are the two main roles for that
test
it's not for latent regular we've been
talking about
thank you so much dr tanasi now could
infection with sars-ko v2
increase the chance of latent tb
becoming active
well that's a very relevant question and
absolutely
true anything that makes someone that
affects somebody's immune system and
compromises in particular their
pulmonary function can reactivate tb
so we have not seen a lot of studies on
that there's a lot of reports of
co-infection
um some case reports of you know 40
people in one country um
you know others have a few at a time
where they're co-infected i don't think
we have had enough time
to show that reactivation happens but um
clearly logically it is happening and i
think we will see it happen more
and i think that people who have had
covid who are these long haulers
and have some residual and chronic
pulmonary disease are also going to be
more susceptible to that latent tb
reactivating
so i'm sorry i don't have an exact paper
to refer you to
but i know that there are reports of
that and i know that and it makes
medical sense to us all
that um reactivation will occur in
people who
uh whose immune system is hit so hard
now i think
actually it's kind of an interesting
question because with covid the immune
system gets
actually ramped up more than it would
normally um
so actually it'll be interesting to see
those studies but my guesstimate is
absolutely
so how are we for time
we're doing great and we have time to to
answer a couple more questions
um this next one regarding the igra
method
could the agro method be applied as well
for kuvid diagnostic
you know it's a terrific question and
i'm gonna i'm not gonna
fake it i'm gonna confess that i
don't know um it would make sense that
interferon gamma release assays which
are releasing
interferon gamma which is common in
everybody's
immune system could respond
to the spike protein
or to a portion of coronavirus
also if that groin virus were so
isolated if the correct antigens were
isolated well let me think about it
um i'd have to think about that one it's
why i didn't market early
i'm not i'm not sure
i'm not sure i think that that would be
trickier i don't know that the body will
have built up
enough a quick i don't know
i'm going to stop i'm not sure i'd have
to think about that one uh whoever asked
the question
get back to me maybe we can do an email
as i think
i'm inferred immunotech or kyogen to see
what they're
doing with those thank you so much and
we have time for
thank you for stopping the champa over
here
we have time for one more question dr
thanasi
and our audience member wants to know
what's your personal
opinion about the pipeline on new
biomarkers aiming diagnostic
test incipient latent tb population
and are you aware of the diagnostic us
teams working toward this
you know i haven't looked at that in the
last few years
at different biomarkers i know that a
lot were being
tried a couple years ago
when i was looking at it and i don't
know what the new pipeline is and so if
this asker is aware of those and wants
to put anything in the chat or
is able to put something in the
questions about that to educate us that
would be great
i think that 6 and cfp10 are pretty good
right now they're pretty accurate i'm
not sure how many more biomarkers we
would need
but if we can increase the sensitivity
and specificity of the testing that
would always be
everybody's goal and definitely the goal
of
everybody working in the field of
tuberculosis
absolutely and dr sanasi thank you so
much for your presentation would you
like to provide our audience members
with any closing remarks before we go
only that you're obviously a well-versed
audience your questions are
tough and interesting and very forward
thinking
and i really love that kind of thought
process where so many of you asked sort
of what is this going to look like going
forward
and i'll be really excited when we get
live conferences again and i can go
meet all of you hopefully and have those
discussions and attend those meetings
where
we work together to continue to make the
world better so thank you for that thank
you
to being invited to this and to
everybody who took their time
uh with us this morning well we want to
thank you again
dr zanasi for your time and in your
important research and we'd also like to
thank
lab roots and our sponsor dia soren for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay so please
encourage and share this email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time everyone stay
safe and stay healthy
and take care bye